hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us let's get into it
hey mark Normand here I'm answering the
internet is that it alright thank you
sir
would you rather build your own shelter
or hunt for your own food oh god I gotta
go uh I gotta go hunt you build a
shelter a cult starts and then you got
hobos everywhere I mean I I would gladly
hunt food I mean you can just go to
Walmart and get a [ __ ] a K I would
just go out in the woods and just start
shooting natives and really really live
it up well what would it be shelter like
a homeless shelter oh yeah who wants to
do that that's brutal I mean can I go to
Home Depot or do I have to like live on
the land alright otherwise you just go
to Ikea and go nuts
alright oh there we go if you could [ __ ]
anyone you wanted but they died
immediately after who would you pick wow
man I guess I'd [ __ ] Cosby you know bang
him right up the pooper sweater on
eating the jell-o pudding pop and I'd be
a hero
I [ __ ] Cosby to death and I would drug
him how great would that be
oh yeah I also wouldn't mind banging
Betty White
because what a way out you know cuz
she's like what 89 or 98
yeah ya know it was a good run and she
went out happy I finally got her off
yeah
anyway yeah
are there sacred days when you refuse to
masturbate funerals tragedies religious
holidays etc now I jerk off pretty much
every day I don't want to give any day
too much energy you know 9/11 Katrina
Holocaust like a Holocaust was not a day
but yeah I'll jerk off anytime anywhere
I don't know what you guys get I get
hard at weird times I'll be at a funeral
like I don't know what's going on here
my aunt's not even attractive that open
casket gets me every time
but yeah I'll rub one out anywhere and I
feel like it makes me a better person
so if you want me to go to that kids
party it's better if the pipes are clean
you know you don't to go to a kids party
all jacked up with a half a chub you
know yeah they've never get invited back
would you rather be able to [ __ ] any
girl you wanted or teleport anywhere in
the world I would rather teleport
anywhere in the world cuz then you can
you could bang a gal and Iraq you know
so I would teleport well you you could
teleport in the vag you could just pop
in she's like what the [ __ ] well I guess
that's tell a rape but I don't want to
be that guy sorry I take it back but I
will teleport because I travel all over
doing comedy and it stinks so I can just
pop into Denver instead of having to
take a United flight next to some fat
guy if you had to win a game show to
stay alive which game show would you
choose Wow I guess I got to go with To
Catch a Predator is that a game show
alright can you win To Catch a Predator
I guess if you have sex with a kid and
get away with it that's
winning no no I guess I'd go I go
millionaire is that still on how to be a
million who wants to be a millionaire
you would you can win that was on the
line so I have to actually still get it
right oh yeah I don't get it my no win a
game show to stay alive oh I say god I
say oh I got it children's jeopardy I
can kick those kids s I'm eight year old
a [ __ ] nerd yeah I'll take him down
who's the first president oh yeah you
[ __ ] kids are done if you could be
homeless in any city where would you
choose woo let's see I would probably go
San Diego first of all you got the
weather you got the beach you don't have
to get snowed on all the people seem
attractive III go San Diego you can walk
around everywhere take the train there's
a subway there yeah not not funny
that's a good point
that's a good point yeah I'd rather have
a tiny shoebox in New York than a than a
under a bridge in Sandy Sandy Hook
would you rather be able to have sex
with any five people for a year or get
to powerbomb whoever you want whenever
you want for a year
powerbomb meaning really pound a lady oh
all right I thought that was gay gay
code or some power bomb should be I had
a power bomb last night at the show
let's see I'd go I definitely have sex
with five people per year because I mean
power bomb is still go to jail if you
owe no repercussions power bomb Trump or
Kathy Griffin or Oprah or anybody
yeah all right I might and can I go can
I put it online oh yeah all right well I
would powerbomb Oprah right right there
you get a powerbomb you gonna powerbomb
you get a powerbomb yeah that would be
fun maybe Jared the subway guy or
something yeah have fun with that be a
hero would you rather have your
girlfriend get a notification every time
you watch porn with a description or
notification where you're at at all
times
I go porn I go porn I don't want her
knowing where I am because I'm not
probably at a porn store you know so I
would definitely go porn that way also
you could use it you could be like oh
he's watching porn again he's probably
at home I'm like little do you know I'm
watching porn and a
convent or whatever you know who has the
easier job Santa Claus or the Easter
Bunny obviously the Easter Bunny I mean
Santa Claus has got to be all over
although you mrs. the Jews so that saves
them a couple 6% of America but yeah I
go Easter Bunny although then you got to
deal with teeth you know you're picking
up kids teeth it's creep you're in a
kid's room it's a little oh [ __ ] sorry I
didn't have a childhood I was beaten my
dad [ __ ] me yeah
sorry I guess still rather be the Easter
Bunny though you know although Santa's
getting the cookies I bet he's plowing
some single moms from that chimney
you never know she's like what's going
on down there and he's like come here
you [ __ ] I got a gift for you blah blah
blah but yeah Easter Bunny what a gig
you know you're eating chocolate it's
fun if you could have an endless supply
of anything what would it be
poo jeez mm maybe peanut butter I go
through about two jars a week I love
peanut butter yeah I just spoon it yeah
I go take a middle finger index AI do a
like a high school finger bang to that
jiff yes so peanut butters up there eggs
I eat a hard-boiled egg every day oh
yeah yeah I don't think about that yeah
I'm basically rocky oh [ __ ] you're right
well yeah I guess I'll go uh money good
call let's go in cash would you rather
be Magic Johnson with AIDS or a regular
dude with no AIDS mmm wait seems pretty
manageable now you know I know some
regular dudes with no AIDS who might as
well have AIDS because they're just
[ __ ] going nowhere and they look like
hell so I might go magic God you know
I'm sure he's having a good time he's
got a couple restaurants he's
is he married yeah aids is nothing now I
go age
give me out decades right now so I bring
it on I mean I'd rather the Magic
Johnson with AIDS in Kobe hey I'll see
you all in hell cavity